طريق صباحي معتاد يوم دراسي وزملاء صفه
على حاله لم يستطع التمييز ان ثمه تحولا
طالزيه المدرسي وابعد
طلاب كابل مدارس البنين في افغانستان
تحولت تدريجيا الى مراكز للتطرف والارهاب
وفق مجله الفرن بوليسي
مدارس التعليم وان تبدلت اشكالها اختصرت
اغلبها على هذا طلاب منكبون على الهجاء
منهم من وجد لنفسه طموحا هنا
ناتي هنا بشغف وحماس للدراسه ولان نصبح في
المستقبل اشخاصا حافظين للدين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خاف لا يمشي بتفاؤل براي متابعين اطفال
اختصر تعليمهم على منهجا بفكر طالبان
مدارس طالبان مصانع تديم الجهل وتحرض على
الكراهيه لانتاج ارهابيين اما على اطراف
افغانستان تلقين لا سقف له فكر امتدا الى
هنا ايضا مدارس على بساطتها كانت اول
المطبقين لمفاهيم طالبا
طالبان تريد اعاده تعريف المفاهيم مثل
الحريه وحقوق الانسان والسلام والمساواه
بحسب تفسيرهم الخاص للتعاليم اذا طلاب
بقدرات محدوده قراءه وكتابه لا اكثر سبعه
ملايين ونصف المليون طالب في اخر احصائيه
يعرضهم ضيق الافق اما للتطرف او لمستقبل
لا صفاء فيه غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات